you may be more familiar with this topic
as oh yeah all that rubbish about the
alphas and the beaters and the - be on a
summon product of routes okay so I keep
on telling you right this topic
polynomials much of it is quadratics
ballon steroids and it's no more obvious
than here so before we get on to the
real polynomials and the reason why I'm
calling up the it is because I'm not
just some a product of roots let's just
revise what you learn from you 10 which
is that you can get a relationship
between the roots of a quadratic and the
corphish is the quadratic okay 1 define
for the other alright so if we say write
a quadratic equation
right if you remember back um there's a
whole new subtopic on constructing
project equations and polynomials right
so if you know what the roots of
according to God you know you could
factorize it in this way okay however we
also say normally that um sorry I should
actually have an a over here because
remember right if I said say the roots
are 1 & 2 x equals 1 and x equals 2 then
this equation here and satisfy that it
would have roots at x equals 1 and x
equals 2 all right if I put a 3 at the
front it would still have the same roots
and if I put a minus 3 out front it
would still have the same roots what
difference would it have if it's gonna
have the same roots yeah so say how
strips down we'll have squashed it is so
if I put it at 1 or 2 right so you might
have one frog look like this or you
might have one like this or one like
this and they all still satisfy this
condition of a given M right so
therefore that's why I put an A at the
front now these are the roots what about
the coefficients were all the customary
way of writing that a general form of a
quadratic equation looks like so right
so in order to get the relationship out
in the most obvious way there's a couple
ways to do it but I could divide through
by a
okay and then in a very similar way to
how it did with auxilary angle right I'm
going to expand one side except instead
of treating expansion I just got right
and then I'm going to compare my
coefficients do you remember how we did
that we go to the wrinkle so let's go
ahead and do it what are we gonna get
here let's see x squared okay
so there's just my expansion and now I
just want to write in a form that makes
my comparison of coefficients the most
direct right so that x squared at the
front my props now I'm going to have a
building here and that's with the that's
what the X term okay so here are my X
terms so if I suck a minus sign like
that right
that's where my son of roots comes from
and there's my product already hanging
over on the end okay sir by comparison
of coefficients
what are you going eat well - the Sun
roots that gives you be on a which gives
you this more familiar result and Mike
mines
the product is so okay now it's worth
mentioning that you can do exactly the
same thing by taking these two results
right and say well I know what those
roots are going to be if this is my
quadratic equation okay
then actors the quadratic formula and
say alpha is going to be this root and B
is going to be the other one and you can
verify this result these two results
down here who are which are the first of
for your tears results you can verify
the by literally look together and you
get this you see it by the way will you
add them together because they're
conjugates right this minus and this
plus will cancel you'll get minus to me
on to a everyone right and anyway and
here okay you multiply and again because
it's difference of squares right this B
will minus B at this B squared they're
also gonna cancel out so you're gonna
end up with for AC on for a squared
multiply it out right and you can see a
cancel cancel cancel cancel see you a
right so you could go either those
methods and get your results okay now
what I'd like you to do even though you
can probably sort of anticipate it but
we do need to be able to prove it okay
is to raise it up one power so if I put
the degree up to three I'm not going to
get that equation I'm gonna have a cubic
equation with roots alpha beta gamma
okay actually like I've seen gamma
written like ten different ways okay so
just write something that looks vaguely
recognizable it doesn't look like any
other line up that you're gonna confuse
it okay
it's the third letter yes I guess it's
gamma gamma ray
yeah well that's what happens when your
ancient in what I'd like you to do right
now and x5 with it is rehearse the way
that we did this for quadratics okay
would you do it for cubies as well okay
so your first line is going to look like
this except you're also going to have an
X minus gamma here right and your right
hand side is got a little bunch of same
except it'll be X cubed DX squared CX MD
okay and then go through and do the same
okay
and we'll catch up in a couple minutes